So the question is, what's the purpose of the minimum viable product?
It turns out that the answer is pretty specific.
You want to test the ability of some portion of your product and meet minimal customer needs
and that might change over time but as the MVP slowly grows
as your confidence in what the customer archetype is.
It's not how to get as much as revenue as you can as early as you can.
You might decide that's a strategy but that's kind of a counter in learning from an MVP.
You typically only make this choice when you actually feel pretty certain
that you understand product market fit.
And while we certainly want to identify bugs in a product
hopefully if we've been using an agile methodology,
we kind of squash most of them before they've gone out the door.
Explicitly the goal of an MVP is not an engineering alpha or beta test.
The goal was not to use this process to find all the bugs though they might come up.
The goal of an MVP is to actually test the ability of the product
to meet minimal customer needs as in choice one.